what's up tat K Harvey I'm missing
today's episode I was on the road and
our boy Patrick Bet David was in town it
was this was shot on a Thursday I think
I was in Orlando so Brian did a uh
fireing kid pod on his own uh with one
of the greats Patrick Bet David is my
brother from a very smart mother so
enjoy this pod with Brian and our boy
Patrick hopefully it's not too boring
come on bri Brian come on Brian I will
be in Chicago December 8th and 9th Brian
is all over the place where's Brian Ken
at so I'm in Chicago December 8th and
9th Brian will be at good nights this
week that's November 9th and 10th and
11th good nights that's in North
Carolina things in Calgary yuck yucks
November 16th through the 18th go get
your tickets to see the big gay owl
Brian Ken brian.com yes we cuz we back
at it's the fighter in the kid this is
really the fighter in the kid come on
baby are we rolling we're rolling
Patrick B David dude um I'm so excited
my man and sha shab couldn't be here and
almost literally was trying to figure
out a way to fly back I was like he
couldn't do it he has this R Florida
I've never seen him be this excited
about you being on a podcast and this
upset he he goes call me when he gets
here has he ever done that ever so he
just he knows he's a huge car ask him
about the cars ask him about owning the
Yankees ask him about he just had a
thousand questions for you he's at Mr
Olympia the question is is he going to
be competing is this going to be
imposing and well he doesn't have the
body for that but he has the strength
yeah he's Bam Bam he's a gorilla he's a
he's a big boy yeah but you you
bodybuild you I I used to yeah back in
the days it was like this was my dream I
was going to be a Mr Olympia you know
marry a Kennedy be a governor you know
going to Hollywood and then boom yeah
took a complete left turn you have
become for me and for a a lot of people
this this voice that what I really
appreciate about the show and you is
that you take on all comers you'll
interview a Marxist Economist who
apologizes for Stalin you you know
you're you're you're there to learn and
listen to all different sides you push
back you're always respectful but you
are interested it seems in real dialogue
and having your mind changed and having
your mind expanded but also but also I
know where you stand politically I know
where you stand economically
philosophically I think we have a clear
understanding of that so you hold that
line which I appreciate because I think
you and I are very
aligned but it's very it's very
refreshing to see somebody that doesn't
purify their Echo chamber to see
somebody that is willing to take on all
comers and actually listen even if you
don't agree with them so my question is
how did that start you you became very
successful as a business guy I mean you
write these books I got friends like
dude blah blah blah they love you you
become this Guru you know but then you
said what you said I want to I want to
expose myself to the ideas the Big Ideas
what politics so you got to realize I
mean my Mom and Dad my mom said they
were Communists my dad side they're
imperialists so so the biggest debate
I've seen in my life opposite track baby
Hillary Clinton and Trump the biggest
debate I ever saw my life was the first
10 years of my Mom and Dad it was
Gabriel versus Diana wow every night
it's an argument over uh you know rich
people are greedy and poor people are
lazy that's the argument my dad side
would say the reason why poor people are
poor is because they're lazy and my mom
would say the Reon rich people are rich
cuz they're greedy and we had this one
Uncle that's a fundamental divide by
very interesting div it is it is so I'm
in the middle of saying yeah you're
right rich people are greedy and yeah
you're right they are lazy but man I'm
confused which route do I go and and
then later on you go through
experiencing it for yourself and you
kind of trying is his mom right is Dad
right and what's going on here and
parents don't realize sometimes you say
something and then you and I are busy
and we'll just kind of walk away and we
forget to come back and follow I
remember one time a guy who was uh uh uh
uh teaching me about being a sales
leader he says listen let's say you had
a big month and you made 50k in a month
one of your sales guys made $3,000 in a
month he's having a bad
month and you're on a call with him and
you're giving him a hard time cuz maybe
he's not running appointments he's not
working hard he's not doing his thing he
says you get off the phone you made 50k
that month he gets off the phone he made
$3,000 that month he's down he doesn't
feel good about himself he says make
sure that that call ends with you
lifting him up don't go to sleep do not
allow that guy to go to sleep without
you lifting him up soing good yeah so
let's just say you don't had a call and
you chewed my ass out you're like dude
what was this all about you doing and
I'm go all right man yeah you're right
and then I get off the phone and I'm
thinking about our conversation all
night but he's saying you call me and
say listen as tough as I'm on you I
believe in you right but sometimes as
parents we don't do that our parents
didn't do that so it's like they say
something 22 years you believe it well
maybe that's right so yeah you get
defined don't you yeah at 33 years old I
I pulled my mom aside one day I'm like
can I ask you a question what was your
problem with luted what was your problem
with this guy this guy was the decam
million of our family like he lived in a
7200 foot house in up by San Antonio if
you know the Drive San Antonio right
next to Snoop I would go to his house
you'd walk in office over here with a
library bedroom all the way down with a
jacuzzi living room you walk to your
left and then there was a big kitchen
with Island he would always stand in the
middle and make breakfast for all of us
I'd sit there as a kid walk D I love how
you know cuz you put that map in you
that's the house I'm getting that was
your goal you went exactly you got that
Palace in your head and you were like
I'm gonna fill that out but I tell you
we went there once a year and I wouldn't
say a single word but I watched
everything he ever did right then I go
to the left he had a pool table with a
picture of his family with all dressed
in white white and this guy was a
conservative but he had a picture of Al
Gore in him on the wall next to the fax
machine and then on this side he had one
of those big box TVs the 70 inch but
it's like 10,000 lb and we'd watch
Jordan play on Sundays if we're there
NBC time and you walk outside swimming
pool basketball court tennis court he
had a a bird's nest on this side and I
would watch him and he he was like this
10 of his kids are sitting outside
they're big Christians he says you know
what I had a thought this week I don't
believe Jesus is real what do you think
and then they would start debating for
two hours damn he would always poke all
his kids constantly he would poke to
spark debate constantly wow and I'm
watching this guy I'm just taking notes
I'm like okay you know my dad works at a
99 Cent Store my mom ran out of money
went back to Iran but I'm going to lock
on to this guy can I one day have this
guy's life okay okay so I aspired to be
Luther Al he died a few years ago and uh
it's pretty wild I got to tell you the
story when this guy died bro so anyways
later on at 33 I'm having this meeting
with my mom I said Mom what was your
problem with this guy what did he do why
did we not like this guy he says you
know what I'll tell you now he says
because when he made his first money we
never saw him again I said Mom the guy
is busy busy he says you know what
you're probably right but at that time
you don't know you're thinking he thinks
he's better than everybody else and we
don't see him anymore right course so
we're at rafi's Place uh uh four years
ago 6 months before he dies and his
daughter
Jackie uh uh sees me and he says hey you
know my dad's here I said dude I'd love
to see your dad so I walk over to his
dad her dad she he stands up can I tell
you something he says yes I said you you
probably saw me as that 12 13 14 15 year
every year I came to your house once a
year and I watch you like a hawk and for
10 minutes I recited every single detail
about what he would do he starts crying
this this he's 90 years old at this time
bro I say to him Uncle lter you have to
realize this you changed my life I said
you're the only thing I could lock on to
to say this is possible he's a Syrian
from Iran if I work like him one day I
can have that life I'm not even your kid
or even related to you but you changed
my life he did it with example he did it
with example so for me you know this
whole concept of sitting down talking
politics this has been an interesting of
mine for a long time so when I made the
transition our content's always been
business entrepreneurship all this stuff
for the first seven years it was all
Niche that's all I talked about and then
it was interviewing Mobsters Sammy you
know Sammy came over he did a great job
with him and then it was Mobsters then
it was you
know China bodybuilding all these niches
I would get into johnf Kennedy
assassination and then I can't help
myself with politics so we're at 3
million subscribers on vment I said you
know what I want to talk
politics but I haven't sold the company
yet and it's risky if I do because I'm
running an insurance company at the time
with 25,000 insurance agents and 60% are
democratic Democrats and 40% are
Republican 54% are Hispanic and so
you're dealing with this
African-American Hispanic Community they
know I'm dealing with politics so I'm
like listen guys here's what what I
stand for but I respect you but I'm
going to have the conversation this is
what your Co stands for and eventually
we start our first podcast first time we
do the podcast on a brand spanking new
channel pbd podcast 57 people are
watching life and then next you know
next one next one dude we got seven
comments bro we're back at at it again
who's this guy that just commented
that's sick what did he say and then
that grew and then obviously you know
people would say he's making a mistake
it's the cardinal rule you should never
go from Talking business to politics
Patrick's going to be dead it's over
with just yesterday crossed five today
crossed 5 million subscribers by P
podcast like 1.5 but we're just getting
warmed I watched you build this yeah we
there is whatever you're interested in
like I watch you and and I love having
you on our podcast when I do and you'll
go somewhere I'm like okay it's obvious
this guy's uh uh dad was a former
plumber he was never involved in
anything with you know of course nothing
to do with intelligence zero nothing why
because I lived all over the world of
course that's got nothing to do with
you're just a regular guy just a regular
dude so when I listen to I'm like okay
this guy's got a lot of things he has
opinions for three four five deep levels
and then the audience finds you and says
I'm kind of weird like you too and
you're like oh you're out there too man
there's millions of us yes you know what
my father used to always say to me he
would say never be it's a you steep
yourself in the Big Ideas understand
like immerse yourself in the best that's
been thought and said so do you have to
have a command of of of the competing
ideas he said but never ever be an
intellectual I said what do you mean he
said there's always an answer look for
the truth the truth you can find and the
truth is a hard line a lot of times
don't be a relativist don't be like well
sometimes yeah they killed a bunch of
people but you know in that case
historically it's not there's an answer
there's a right there's a wrong there's
a good there's an evil he was always
about that so you can be you can be
immersed in the big ideas but the Trap
is you hear a lot of people for example
now saying look I'm I'm I'm Pro Humanity
I'm anti- murder that's nice for you bro
but you don't come from a certain part
of the world where philosophical and
political commitment
is everything and if you're on the wrong
side of that line they come to your
house and they kill you you understand
and I think being a Syrian being Iranian
the way you were you don't have that
choice but I think it's fascinating that
one man can be a great businessman and
obviously a great father with all his
kids and just be living his life and you
see him once a year dude and you just
got a map I mean the way you describe
that house you you had a you were a
goore and a dude which I always say is
the most important thing you you you saw
what you wanted your life to look like
in Technicolor in 4D and and here we are
let's take a little break from K just
chatting chatting our boy Patrick's air
off let me give uh Patrick a little
break and you guys a break mark your
calendars because November 11th is going
to be a big
boy Yi versus Alex Pier is going down
this Saturday UFC 295 you got Tom asol
and pavlovich fighting for the interm
heavyweight belt really the real
heavyweight belt but only one fighter
will leave with the belt secure your
Victory with unbeatable offers on
draftking Sportsbook new customers
strike now to get $200 instantly in
bonus bets when you bet
$5 uh my boy Matt my my boy Matt
Steamroller is a big dog you can make
some Bank on him uh get in on UFC 295
action with DraftKings right now that's
right this Saturday it is going down for
the Brown you got the light heavyweight
championship belt on line you got the
interm heavyweight championship belt on
the line Tom asol pavlovic you also got
freaking Yi versus Alex Pier I can't
wait for this Saturday and you can join
the boys the official Sports B partner
of the UFC download the app right now
use the code fighter talking about
DraftKings new customers get 200
instantly in bonus bets when you bet $5
that's code fighter only on draftking
sports book The Crown is yours gambling
problem call 1800 gambling or visit www1
1800 gambler. net in New York call 8778
hope Andy or text hope Andy 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 888- 78977 77 or
visit
cpg.io in Ontario bonus bets expire 168
hours after issuance see
sportsbook.com / MMA terms for
eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible gaming resources
look man I'm just trying to help you
guys make smart Investments with
everything going on in the world you got
the wars the inflation the economy right
now could be the best time ever to
diversify your money and savings with
precious medals like gold and silver get
your Scrooge McDuck on man look how rich
he ended up I bought some precious
medals myself and I got them from the
top rated company talking about gold Co
they couldn't have made it freaking
easier goold has helped thousands of
people place over 2.5 billion in gold
and silver they're a rated A Plus by the
Better Business Bureau they've earned
over 5,000 fstar reviews they're seven
time Inc 5,000 winner and that's just
mentioned a few of their accomplishments
there's so much more right now the fire
kid listeners and viewers they're
offering you guys up to $10,000 in bonus
silver while supplies last go to Gold
code.com fighter to learn more we don't
talk about money a lot all right but
this going to help you diversify your
portfolio so go to Gold code.com fighter
today that's gold code.com
fighter because I watched you it was
very interesting to watch you build this
thing methodically because you would you
would have these conversations I get
sucked in you'd be talking to Sammy the
bull you'd have these debates and you'd
just be sitting there listening and it
was just your face cuz you were
literally learning my my my thing about
Rogan his his success is basically
because he says wow a lot cuz he's he's
learning with us wow that's what
he's learning with us you know I was
doing this podcast when we were in a
[__] in a in a
garage so it's the same thing and then I
would watch you stop and I be I sucked
in you go hey guys if you like this hit
this never did it but I eventually did
I'm moving on but then I eventually did
you did it 50 times after a while I'm
like I got to listen to the rest of this
dude yeah classic and now you've become
I think this guy who you're just I don't
know so this was all you knew you were
going to get here this was the goal you
you did you did the insurance thing
entrepreneur you make your money and now
now you're a guy who wants to Foster
debate now you want to get involved you
you're on Rogan I I love that Rogan goes
did you come on here to get me to
endorse Trump I said not endorse Trump
but I think you know you not having him
on the show is helping Biden that's what
the argument was about but uh you know
it's wild uh uh while we're doing that
podcast guess who text me Trump was
watching a podcast in his plane
oh my God their entire we have a picture
their entire Camp is up there watching
the podcast from the plane and uh you
know that was a message coming off of
course by the way if they end up doing
it uh the
podcast it's got to be time properly you
know today may not be the time to do it
it's probably got to be more second or
third quarter of next year you know post
maybe RNC type of a thing maybe
September October
is the ideal time to do cuz it'll break
it but again one thing about Joe Joe's
going to do what Joe's going to do Joe's
the booker he's going to do what Jo's
going to invite whoever he wants to
invite and that's why the world loves
Joe yeah well he's just honest y he just
he's he's basically tells and he's
multi-dimensional it's very hard to find
multi-dimensional type of people the
other day we created a scorecard and
this scorecard I'm I'm having a talents
dinner with my guys and these are guys
that are creating content Vinnie Adam
all these guys are at the house and I'm
going I'm trying doing great by VIN
doing really good Vinnie
by the way one of the funniest Vinnie
oan is one of the funniest comics on the
planet people don't realize it and they
need to cuz he's and I'm so impressed
with what he's doing now he's just wared
up yeah yeah bro but you know how much
he's changed his life his decisions what
he's doing right I don't if you know
what he's doing I called him up I go
dude I I don't I'm loving this new look
cuz he's he's following your lead yeah
he and and he's he's doing it like he's
not breaking at all you know he he won't
take I mean he's he's in a very good
place but but we're having we're having
this dinner and we cre Creed these four
criterias and we gave everybody a
scorecard and I said give me any name
and let's give you a score okay so the
score was based on personality are you
likable okay content how
multi-dimensional are you with content
then next was entertaining and then
there's one other part uh uh that we
added to the to the whole thing so the
highest score we had everybody on the
list that we went through we had like 30
40 names the highest score was a tie
between Trump and and uh uh and Rogan
because they're entertaining you
personalties is attractive personality
right content they can go in different
places and it's a wild thing that those
guys ended up being at the top but we
put a lot of other guys on the list some
guys are very smart but they're not
entertaining some guys are very
entertaining but they're not very smart
their depth is low right some guys are
you don't trust them guys don't trust
this guy you know you're not likable
there's something about you rubs me the
wrong way every once in a while you find
a multi-dimensional person and that
guy's upside is not going to be hard
he's going to work how is's he going to
use his talent and that's why Joe's the
goat that's that's 100% what do you see
as a guy who's so keyed into the
Zeitgeist and you know business politics
you know I always say guys like you are
I listen to guys like you because you've
come into contact with reality I mean
there's a measurable you know criteria
for whether or not your business is
doing well or not so I you know if you
run a business like your insurance
people how many people were working for
you now when I'm saying when your
business before you sold it oh 45,000
insurance agents when we sold it now
yeah so you know I always say in that
situation you're looking for results you
can't be thinking about you're not
you're not there's no there's no like
well I need a quot of black people here
a quot of brown people you need results
man and if the guy has you know if the
guy comes in dressed like Tinkerbell if
he can sell you got job that's that's
the bottom line that's why I like
capitalism and markets um but what do
you see and now you're of course now
you're interviewing everybody Under the
Sun who's who's a politician what do you
see as the biggest threat to our
democracy right now to our democracy
yeah do you do you wor what keeps you up
at night well right now we are one
person being offended from World War III
being started okay today that's the
biggest concern today it's changing and
it's changing really really quickly so
there's a few things you know in a
household the reason why uh boys need a
father because sometimes moms uh can't
bring these two elements at a level
that's needed for example I'm I'm I'm
having Tom Brady at the event we're
having a conversation and I said to Tom
I said Tom I noticed the people that do
something very big with their lives not
small but massive like they can't stop
like you can't stop musk musk can be a
trillionaire tomorrow he's still working
the same way the next day
mus can go buy a house the biggest house
ever and 200,000 ft with the most crazy
thing in there he's coming to work the
next day same time that's musk he's not
going to stop okay because musk had
something that others don't have he had
it Brady has it Jordan has it Trump has
it a few people have it you need three
things okay number one you have to have
experienced unconditional love when
you're growing up cuz you have to know
that's possible unconditional love
typically comes from a mom you need it
it's
Unique you know you can screw up you can
get arrested but your mom your mom she's
on death row she's the one she's the one
right that's right that's that's the mom
element of Love sometime it's not Mom
for everybody sometime it's that but for
the most part it's Mom number
two you need to have someone in your
life that you loved so much so much that
betrayed you you need that you need one
person in your life that you would have
taken a bullet for that absolutely Ely
betrayed you and broke your heart almost
destroyed you and no matter what you do
you can never win this person over
nothing you can make all the money in
the world you will never convert them
you can have the best six-pack biggest
muscle win a UFC Championship you will
never win this person over and it's a
never it's not I finally win them over
you will never win them over so one
unconditional love two is the element of
somebody destroy your heart and no
matter how much you win they're never
going to be on your side and last but
not least is the reason why I wrote this
book choosing your enemies wisely most
people choose The Wrong Enemy most
people have no clue what they're doing
to themselves they're absolutely
choosing the wrong enemy in their lives
you choose The Wrong Enemy all of a
sudden you you could use waste 20 years
of your life 30 years of your life right
okay so for example if we go to choosing
enemies wisely let's Choose The Wrong
Enemy uh feminist movement who's the
enemy men men are the enemy yes I'm
holding a vault conference two years ago
and on first day we do a personal
identity audit list of questions you got
to go through it's the homework the next
morning we talk about it so you got to
go by yourself that night and go through
these questions we got a couple thousand
people in attendance from 40 plus
countries next day I'm on stage and I'm
saying who wants to tell us what big
breakthrough you have one guy says this
one husband and wife say this one then
one girl is sitting over you with her
sister and her sister saying raise your
hand raise your hand raise your hand
finally she says I have to do it I said
what's that she says I'm 39 40 years old
about to turn 40 in a month she says I
make more money than any one of my
cousins siblings I'm the one every boy
that I wanted to beat I beat I made more
money than them I drive a nice car I
live in a beautiful house I go to
whatever restaurant I want I have all
the Chanel pures I'm miserable and I'm
lonely yeah and I'm lonely she says
she's crying telling the story she says
last night I realized men are not the
enemy now we've seen this in many movies
before right when there's a he's not the
enemy like the whole thing with Jerry
Maguire with a girl is sitting around
with all these other I don't care I love
him right I don't care all all the
divorced couples are bitching about
their husbands and men and all this
stuff and then Jerry walks in so it's
not like it's new story but she had a
breakthrough feminism one of the worst
enemies ever example was for women women
it just hasn't it hasn't panned out this
concept of choosing your enemies wisely
it applies to countries it applies to
Wars it applies to politics it applies
to Faith it applies to business it
applies to podcast it applies to
yourself lot you're you think that
you're going to protect yourself by and
all your attention is going over here
when the enem is over here it's
everything it's it's such a wise it's
such a great subject because but you
have business planning for the audacious
few it has a business can I can I read
something out of that for you check this
out watch this okay I want to get back
also to going to break your heart watch
this here watch this here check this out
I'm going to read two quotes for you
number one okay A wise man gets more
used from his enemies than a fool from
his friends balazar graian now let me
read the other one check this out this
one will give you chills all over your
body you have no enemies you say my
friend the boast is poor he who has
mingled in the fry of Duty that the
brave endure must have made foes if you
have none small as the work you have
done you've hadd no traitor on the hip
you've dashed no cup from the PED lip
you've never turned the wrong to right
you've been a coward in the fight
Charles McKay I'm sitting with Dana
yesterday and I said Dana I got a book
coming out choose your enemy wise it's a
business planning book we're finishing
our meeting and he says What's the title
of the book he said I said choose your
enemy wise he says look at that right
behind me and if you've been to his
office you know what pictur on the wall
it's like that the the the Asian thing
yeah he says no no look at the wall I
said Dana I don't know what I'm looking
said I'm telling you look over here so I
have to stand up and I come around and I
look at the wall and on his wall he has
this picture picture that I have to take
a picture with them he says may God have
mercy on upon my enemies because I won't
and he says you know who said that right
I said who I said is it a general is it
a he says it's a general I said is it
such and such finally was General Patton
may God have mercy upon my enemies
because I want even a Dana White the
famous quote that video when he says
[__] bet against me you know which
one I'm talking about he says bet
against me tell me it's not going to
happen tell me it's going to fail I love
it I love every minute of it right
here's a guy that CH enemies wisely so
you tell you talk this book by the way
this this is for anybody in business it
doesn't matter what you are it's a
formula there's 12 building blocks if
you're going into 2024 and you want 2024
to be the beginning of the greatest
years of your maybe you want to have a
breakthrough most people write a logical
business plan it's boring but this
applies to a podcaster to a businessman
politics military whatever it maybe
comes out December 5th choose your
enemies wisely but going back to the
question you asked about what keeps me
up at
night Israel Palestine
okay we're on this side I can't believe
you're pro- Israel I cannot believe you
just question Netanyahu I cannot believe
you have the audacity to say why isn't
Egypt taking the refugees from Gaza how
could you say such a thing the reason
why they're not taking their refugees
more than 800 a day because Egypt knows
that if people leave Gaza there will no
longer be a Palestine how dare you not
say things about Hamas have you not read
their Charter that their whole goal is
about elimin Jews have you not seen what
they've done to so here's the point
that's okay but I'm not trying to win
I'm I'm I'm I'm not in the game of
making friends with the audience for
them to sit there and say did you guys
like today's episode did you like
today's episode my idea is listen if you
like me today you're going to be upset
with me next week but if you hate me
today be patient you're going to love me
next week cuz I want to have the
conversations so so the part that we
have today we need we need someone that
knows how to lower the temperature
remember the example I gave about mother
K to do certain things that a father can
a father knows how to bring two elements
to to a boy's life fear and respect a
boy needs to fear a man and respect a
man but he also needs love if a father's
also loved and he knows how to bring
love you got to try fector you're like a
Just Timberlake You Can Dance you can
act and you can you know sing so a a
trifect of a father imposes fear once a
quarter earns respect from his kids and
loves on them if you can do that as a
father you have the highest potential of
raising good kids most fathers only
impose fear and there's no respect and
love some fathers are pansies they only
impose love no fear and respect but you
need all three America today our
president doesn't impose fear doesn't
impose respect and is not earning love
from anybody nobody Andrew Schultz said
deaths he says the way I judge a
president is by the merch they sell
Biden ain't moving merch Trump is moving
merch a form of moving merch is what
you're admired your loved what merch are
people buying from have you ever seen
anybody where Joe Biden had have you
ever seen he's a Charisma vacuum and I I
also think that Biden just doesn't stand
for anything he seems to have been
hijacked by the far-left and and I don't
even know there there's no I have my
issues with Trump as a person I think he
tends to be he's such a he's he's a
trumpist he's he's about himself in a
lot of ways but at least there was a
coherent economic and foreign policy
that I follow that I could that I that
that that was something that I could
make sense of when you've got the left
is a snake eating its own tail I don't
even know what they're talking about
half the time you've got them standing
up for the minority but then at the same
time they hate and they at this point
they're they're surrounding Jews uh you
know in Harvard when they're just trying
to walk across the quad I don't even
know how to make this gender ideology I
guess a woman is just an inner feeling
so suddenly I'm a woman now and you have
to call me a woman and if you don't
you're going to get censored I mean what
are we talking about here none of this
makes sense biological males and female
sports what are you what are you talking
about you know so we we can go on and on
but um what what I think what I think is
is very important as to your point is
being clear and concise and speaking the
truth like we know what 2 plus two is
it's four you you I I said about the
Hamas thing look man you want to have
the conversation about Israel Palestine
man that's a no problem there are two
there are two sides to every story
that's a complicated issue you're going
to get into the weeds with that and
nothing I say is going to change your
mind that's a Biblical emotional issue
as much as it is a logical issue but
when you come over a border and you kill
entire families in their pajamas on a
Saturday morning we have to there's a
button called the stop everything button
all of us have to go hold on and you
took kids you took hostages children
entire families I got to hit that button
we got to stop everything because there
are some things that are Beyond The Pale
there there are some things you're a
serial killer you killed a bunch of
people and you come in and go my my
mother was so mean to me and you might
tell me a heartbreaking story about your
mother you got to go bro you still
killed 10 people you you understand
there's just there are there are lines
there are lines we have to defend there
are lines that we have to stand by if
you don't have lines you're willing to
defend if you don't have lines you're
willing to defend and fight for then who
the [__] are you if I don't know what
you want if I don't know what you
honestly rever and what you are willing
to stand up for regard L of the cost
then you're probably not a fully
realized human being and you're
certainly not a fully realized country
and you certainly don't have a fully
realized philosophy that's that's what I
believe and I think you're probably in
the same camp let's take a little break
cuz the holidays are coming the
weather's getting a little freaking gold
out there cozy up in style this fall
with the onm match comfort of meundies
meundies has the softest most breathable
underwear and loungewear that you can
experience whether you're on the grind
during the work week or post it up on
the couch with your girl meundies is is
there to keep you comfy all right from
all black Classics to fun seasonable
prints modern they got Cool Shapes
meundies has a wide range of cuts that
will fit your body all right the they
get the versatile loungewear meandi in
just about Underoos explore the
loungewear collection featuring cozy
joggers hoodies onesies and so much more
the comfort is unmatched all right it's
breathable it's micro modile fabric so
it's so soft on your three-piece set all
right um um if you're not happy with
your first pair of undies it's on me
undies that's right they're so confident
you're going to love them it's a PR free
philosophy that's that's from The Lion
King it's our philosophy anyways uh all
you got to do is get 25% off your first
order plus free shipping go to
meundies.com
tfatk that's meundies.com
tfatk for 25% off plus free shipping
mei's comfort from the outside in yeah
for me you know so so if if I talk to
somebody who is Jewish okay you have to
be able to reason and and realize
there's a high likely you this person is
going to defend whatever Netanyahu is
doing 80% chance okay fine but having
said that half of Israel was against
Netanyahu half of Israel was not for the
illegal settl but but but if I'm talking
to somebody who's Jewish I get what
position you're going to take good I'm
playing the odds game if I'm talking to
somebody that's Muslim I understand what
position they're going to take and
they're going to see Hezbollah as
Freedom Fighters I lived in Iran they
they were not seen as Freedom Fighters
okay people were scared of Hezbollah you
don't see people being frightened of
what our military does in US you don't
see people Marching In the Streets madb
omo or mad about other no one in the
military ever the other day someone's
talking about saying I can't believe you
support this you support this I said
brother I've had the luxury of living in
Iran for 10 years and seeing people
marching down the street flagala their
backs with a trail of blood screaming MB
arria and I have I've had the privilege
of living in a refugee camp the US Army
Amica and I lived in us and I was in the
US Army at the1st Airborne I've never
ever seen us marching saying death upon
China death upon Iran death upon Russia
we've never taken that position but
reason logic okay this book uh called
power versus Force if you've never read
it it's a phenomenal book to read it
talks about levels of consciousness if
you pull a power versus Force chart if
you if you do that and the audience can
see the chart it'll show you from the
lowest level to the highest level okay
on the lowest level you'll see apathy
grief like if you if you pull up the
square one the one to the right right
there yeah if you pull up that one look
at the lowest level right you'll see
right there shame okay guilt apathy
apathy grief fear desire anger Pride all
of those are bad things that's all
fource you gain power when you have the
courage to speak to somebody you
disagree with and then you're able to
stay neutral to the best of your
abilities you're willing to to talk
you're accepting the differences you're
able to reason you're able to love
people and then you have joy peace
Enlightenment which is very difficult to
get to but the point is when you do sit
with somebody that disagrees with you
you have to say he's supposed to I
totally get it I get it it's totally
fine we can have this conversation right
I understand what position you're taking
but at the same time you know for for me
Living in America with four kids it's
going to be America First regardless the
policies have to be America first
it's not any other thing before America
I always say this people who live in
other countries when they come to this
country they're more patriotic than any
any America guess what it should be if
you're part of Hamas you're going to
believe Hamas first if you're
Palestinian it's Palestinian first if
you live in Gaza it's Gaza first if
you're Israel Israel first if you're
China I totally understand that part
you're not you going up against your
opponent you're like well you know the
guy that's playing for the next time
with the Lakers yeah we're best friends
bro we went to high school together no
no he's Nicks first then you he wants to
win the championship then you guys can
be buddies having dinner afterwards when
he gets to ring and now you that level
is very honest and it's straight up you
know when we're talking about Trump how
he's selfish and all this other stuff if
there's anything any show I highly
recommend anybody to anybody who doesn't
know a lot of politics and they just
kind of want to learn I say go watch
Phil Donahue and Milton fredman I don't
know what year it is 1974 or 1980 some
number like that okay yellow I think
he's r a yellow your yellow shirt and
then Phil Don who says what do you say
about all these selfish people and greet
he says oh it's always the other guy
that's greedy you're definitely not
greedy right only I'm selfish right as
if we're not selfish he makes fun of
Phil Phil doesn't have anything to say
and the point being everybody naturally
is selfish by the way we ran a chart
okay in the book we there's a chart that
explains the selfish selfless chart I
don't know if you've seen there's a book
by an ran called The Virtue of self
that's right that's right green B people
so there's this chart that says the net
positive index so we ran this chart and
we had a group of people that we were
doing focus group with to see what's
going to come up with this we said are
who's a net positive to society is a
person that's 100% selfless 0% selfish a
net positive to society or a person
that's 100% selfish 0% selfless who's
more of a net positive you know what it
was the 100% selfish 100% selfish
because at least he's going to be clean
he's not going to smell he's going to
take care of his stuff he's going to
have now is it going to back he might
also create an industry and hire I don't
know uh 100,000 people absolutely but
you know what the number was 5050 people
are good consiliari they're good to
bounce ideas off it they're good board
members right but a good mixture of
somebody you can tolerate working for
but he's still going to kick your ass
and drive you and he's always got
something he's pursuing is a 7030 Mark
it's okay to be 70% selfish and 30%
selfless that's the right combination 60
5 35 7030 that we found so when we work
with people we kind of say what's this
guy here he's a 6040 guy that guy's an
8020 okay we know where to put him
that's a 9010 gu [__] that guy's 110 I
know what I'm dealing with I'm
negotiating with this guy that guy's
2080 I wish you had bigger dreams and I
wish you wanted to do something more
because the world would benefit if you
had bigger aspirations so I don't have a
problem with somebody who is selfish as
long as they're 30% selfless well I
gotta say I want to just tell people
when I did your podcast and you had to
leave town and I this touched me this
Adam Adam sasin says he he hit me up and
he says Hey listen Patrick just wanted
you to know David want I mean Patrick
wanted you to know that if if you want
to use his boat you want to go out on
his boat uh and go to his house he's not
there but you guys can we can take the
boat out and I was like this dude
doesn't need anything from me and he's
offering he's he's just out of the kind
of his heart he's not even in town going
if you want to take the boat out I went
this dude is such a [__] we like your
company bro appr I met you 15 years ago
at Cavalia when I tell the story you're
sitting I'm watching this guy I'm like
oh my God Charisma charm talking to
everybody and and I knew you because
he's like what the f you crazy mother
don't remember me what the [__] I was
playing a Lebanese guy my friend let me
go back for a second because you said
something I've never heard anybody say
now when you're my age and you hear
something you've never heard before you
stop [__] okay I've heard it you love
that betrayed you dude you just said you
need somebody who loves you got it then
you need somebody who breaks your heart
and I couldn't agree more but I never
thought of it this way I need you to
expand on this because I've never heard
anybody say this and I I think you could
make the case that if you understand how
to navigate life anything bad that
happens to you anything bad happens to
you if you navigate it properly if you
understand that it's a chance to grow
anything bad that happens to you is good
and most of the thing the good things
that happen to you especially the ones
that that are given to you whether it's
just being born into a nice family and
stuff those can be handicaps they can be
as much a handicap as they are uh a
benefit talk to me about this where the
[__] did you come up with this well and
it makes so much sense is that in the
book of course it is yeah it it it's and
it's part of uh uh so when you're in the
sales business for 20 years I'm always
sizing people up to see who I should P
pull my time into we we talk about the
concept of 9010 if I find the right guy
I'm better off putting 90% of my time
into 1% 10% into 10 other people
combined than 10 10 10 10 10 10 10
that's PR's principal right that's prto
8020 but I go even more 9010 usually so
so if we go to 9010 and you lock on to
someone now here's a mistake what's the
risk if you lock on to the wrong guy
you're screwed absolutely screwed by the
way the NFL NBA UFC NHL MLB every one of
these leagues has to have some they lock
on to the NBA locked on to LeBron James
the NBA locked on to Kobe Bryan improved
the game on to China the NBA locked on
to Michael locked on to Magic and Larry
this is a concept of now NBS has to find
a next person who to lock on to it's not
Zion is it Giannis who will it be is it
Luca who do you lock on to UFC same
thing who does who do you have to lock
on to you have to find the next guy
that's a showman is it om Ali you know
is it this like even the other day when
you're watching inano and they Fury fied
I'm like there is no way the last two
you saw Fury's back in he's not even
fighting he's hold him he like dude
somebody probably whispered to him don't
do anything don't get in there we're
going to give it to you 46 45 44
whatever the score card was at the end
because we want the other fight the guy
that's sitting over there we can't have
this guyn we going to lose hundreds of
millions of dollars Bob arams did all
this like this is why people don't like
this product right on what's happened to
it but the point with this whole concept
of needing that the 9010 then you have
to size people up okay and you got to be
like let me poke this guy a little bit
test him ooh okay that drives him got it
so tell me what drives you tell me about
your mom and dad tell me about your
upbringing tell me about you know who
were you in high school who are you
closer to Mom and Dad big siblings are
you youngest Middle oldest how
competitive was your family what what
drove you what's your biggest
disappointment what's your biggest
Victory Who challenged you the most who
was tough on you who drove you and then
by the time you're talking to this
person 30 minutes later you'll notice
all if you're paying close attention
like boom that's the trigger got it but
then you'll talk to somebody like like
yeah I don't really know it's all loopy
answers yeah I mean I guess so words
like that I'm not wasting my time with
you you're all loopy and soft and your
eyes are like there's no fire in your
eyes loopy and soft so so I talked to a
guy then all of a sudden 20 minutes into
it you're like Bingo last time we're
doing a podcast with Bradley we do two
hours of podcast last night in Vegas and
then when we get on the flight to come
to Bradley who Bradley from Vegas he's
got his own show right he's he's so I'm
talking to him same thing we start
talking good guy nice guy talented guy
multi- multi-millionaire does very well
for himself got a great life but his
eyes are good life his eyes don't have
fire in it by the time we were done all
night all morning he's hungry oh I can't
even tell you what happened to him
afterwards we're walking away cuz I told
him I said you haven't found your enemy
yet this whole concept about well you
know it's not healthy all this stuff I'm
not talking to you listen I'm either
your cup of tea or I'm not if I'm not
tune off you tune out and go watch
something you're saying you need
the enemy keeps you hungry keeps you
crouched and ready right and by the way
you know typically the person that
drives you the most you can never reveal
it to the world you can never tell the
world it's your secret it's nobody
else's it's not public you never tell
anybody not your wife nobody you have
and it's typically going to be one
that's sacred sacred sacred to you and
I'll tell you a story go for it Todd
Phillips director of The Hang writer
director hangover Bad Santa it just goes
on and on Hangover too I mean he done a
couple movies you know old school
just the Joker you're talking about a
genius Legend and known him for a long
known him now 25 years and uh when I
remember the hangover I was I was on set
and I said I looked at him I go how much
you Mak him for this cuz we're close he
goes he looks at me he goes you're
making more than I am right now I was
making for the scene I was making I
don't know two grand I don't know what I
was making it was for a day I go what
what he goes yeah he bet on himself he
bet on himself he wrote The Hangover why
did he write The Hangover I call him up
after it becomes this
crazy crazy success like just kept
making money it was the he said I'll
take no money I'm GNA hire all these
unknowns in this movie let me own a
piece of this there are three people
that own that movie he was one of them
okay he did pretty well I call him I say
I hope I'm not speaking out of term but
I'm GNA tell you the story I say what
drives you dude what drives you how do
you do this he goes revenge [__] these
[__] and and what drove him was that
he was trying to do old school too but
everybody was too busy MH everybody in
Hollywood was like nah we got this yeah
you had this movie that didn't do very
well called uh it was uh with Billy Bob
Thor and it did nah thanks man you know
you what have you done for this lady he
went oh really oh that's how you want to
play this drops hang over after old
school yeah yeah okay I got you yeah let
me write this [__] down wow yeah that's
what he did and he just went you guys
don't want to do that you don't want to
play how about I write a movie that
changes the landscape and how about I
hire a bunch of unknowns Zach galanakis
he called me up he asked me about Zack I
go I think he's the funniest guy in the
world he goes yeah his eyes cracked me
up nobody knew Zach nobody knew Zach
nobody knew Bradley Cooper Bradley was
doing TV when we were doing hangover
Bradley was taking pictures of me with
tourist because they wanted the guy from
Mad TV Etc they didn't know who he was
he he he hired everybody who was an
unknown bet on himself
Revenge his enemy he had enemy he had a
very clear idea of who the enemy was and
that so so as you're telling me this
story it's very interesting to me but
you say don't reveal it to anybody you
you could so so so usually you
have there's there's 14 types of enemies
so go ahead make your point I want to
see what your question was going to be
it's just you know usually what happens
in life is you have a contract with life
most of us go we we we I I'm going to
work hard I'm going to do the right
thing and God's going to provide me with
the you know all the goodies it's how it
is right that's why the Book of Job is
really about that the Book of Job is
like you're such a you're such a you
know you've been so good you're such a
good guy how come God's not rewarding
you well basically the the the thing
about that is hey this ain't about God's
not a a genie that I it's not a a
lantern I rub he's not a vending machine
if I put in money I'll get good stuff
out sometimes you can put it all in and
think but you keep your faith you keep
moving you keep moving and you use
whatever happens to to you it doesn't it
doesn't bow your head you just keep
moving through the hurricane and you'll
come out the other ey the other end
right so what I'm saying is Well I guess
what what I'm what I'm what I'm saying
is that there there is that idea of you
you you you go through life you have a
contract with life but that contract
always gets ripped up it gets mocked
it's like dude I did everything right
and my dreams didn't come true hey dude
it's not over yet this is the biggest
lesson of your life now you can either
become a better person I always say your
best self your best version of yourself
is clearing his throat in the other room
and you should always be hearing it
every time you're [__] up he's going
hey over here you know we all have that
if you're if you're paying attention so
but again is that what you're talking
about where where the contract gets
ripped up you know two books First Rate
Madness and hypomanic Edge never heard
of them and first R Madness First Rate
Madness and and by the pull up the book
cover First Rate Madness look what the
cover looks like and Look whose faces it
is look the faces of this book are right
there okay yeah that's the one look at
this zoom in a little bit if you could
okay right there look at that who are
those faces Kennedy Abraham Lincoln okay
and it's one other person I think the
left jaw uh the right jaw is LBJ I don't
know who it is but it's Jackson or LBJ
one of those guys okay and it explains
uh uh this other book hypomanic Edge
talks about the elements of bipolar
multi-personality
hypomanic can't go to sleep they're
non-stop their brain keeps going
it just keeps going right and then in
one of the books it talks about how Bill
Clinton what drove him was his
relationship with his mom and in one
interview he said there's no benefit for
me saying bad things about my mom no one
wins if you say bad things about your
mom there is no winning right but that
was one of his enemies that nobody knew
about his mom yeah some some people wow
are many of your enemies publicly others
can guess well bud Crawford Bud Crawford
who I think is the greatest boxer
walking the planet you know um Terence
Crawford uh who took Earl Spence and
dismantled him I I mean I just couldn't
believe it I'm a boxing fan him he's a
genius and his mother his mother never
ever told him really anything that
positive CU she had to play she had to
play mother and father and so no matter
what he did hey man keep going it was
good look at jobs Jobs's mom gives him
up for a do option Foster and then
somebody else picks him up Armenian
mother picks him up and they raise him
his entire life is like you gave me up
to somebody else you think jobs would
ever say that's what drove him you don't
think if you if we go high to top five
cycle people that psychoanalyze them to
realize that's what it was no the the
people that drive us at the highest
level will typically won't reveal it
maybe later on in life we'll re read I
don't know if have you read El musk's
recent book no must read Walter ISAC my
God I love Walter Isaac first of it's
insane so he talks about his
relationship with the dad and what what
happened with him and Kimble and how
they drove him and how he took it to a
whole different level no you know you
need people like that in your life you
need to exper when did you identify your
enemy when did you identify the
Heartbreak well relationship for sure it
happened with with a a girl it happened
when I got out of the army but to me the
one that drove me the most because a
girl may only drive you for 5 to 10
years some enemies lifp is very short
you know maybe 6 months prove them wrong
okay who gives a [__] it's done you went
to the wedding you got a six-pack you
went to the freaking club party you look
good everyone's over it you're not going
to be driven again for the next six
months that's a very short stand of you
need a real enemy a good type of enemy
certain enemies drive you for 20 years
those kinds are freaking phenomenal some
of them are forever some people don't
graduate enemies so they stay at the
same level you got to you got to pick
and choose uh uh what's going to get you
out for me I'm 25 years old I'm I'm
going to a Christmas party with my dad
and I'm there with a bunch of Assyrians
and I'm a nobody at that time this 20
years ago I just turned 45 2 weeks ago
no one has a clue who I am but I'm just
like a guy making 30 grand a year 40
Grand a year that's what I'm doing okay
and I'm broke 49 kid just got out of a
bad relationship three years we're
supposed to get married doesn't work
out I'm at this party at Glendale and
one guy who's a nobody sweetheart of a
guy makes one sarcastic comment about my
dad nothing disrespectful just
sarcastic but he had that look on his
face and I saw the look on my dad's face
he humiliated your dad embarrassed your
dad I mean you listen man I I've told
this story a couple hundred times I'm
there right now you still get [__]
angry oh oh brother yeah so I come back
and I tell my sister and my brother
andow to come to the house I said Dad
the world's going to know how Inc
incredible of a father you were I said
I'm going to work my ass off that when
you go in the streets they're going to
stop you and they're going to tell you
all your son ever talks about as how
incredible father you are wow dude I
can't even tell you what that is so for
me wow is your father still alive 81 he
was in the hospital 5 days he's in the
hospital the guy's doing an angiogram on
him he says Mr B David I know who you
are and I love what your son says about
you he says how do you know who I am he
says you and your son have the same big
nose I recognize that nose
from it was the best D there's only one
other guy I've seen with a nose like
that is your son right but they have a
laugh and he does a surgery he's back at
home he's good but you know wow my dad's
83 still very close to him as well it's
a beautiful it's a privilege isn't it it
is it is it's a privilege it is we're
we're we're part of you ever feel like
you had to gain his approval was he hard
on you or or he was more of a a gentler
soul my dad never put a hand never hit
me one time ever he never disciplined me
but to him he was the guy that he says
never be afraid of the truth you know
beat people with words and results okay
uh if you're going to say you're going
to do something to do with the Basic
Value stuff you know that he would say
and since 6 years old I wanted to be a
father just because I wanted to be like
wow yeah he was my hero you said
something really interesting um you said
you know when you're a young man and
you're successful or even a middle-aged
man and you're successful there's a
tendency because you have access to
everything so why not play the field why
not be single why not 15 women have why
not you know do whatever you want and
live that Snoop Dog lifestyle whatever
it is that people have and you said and
I I couldn't agree more but I'm an older
man you know it's like why in the world
wouldn't you settle down with one person
and have a family there there's nothing
better than that especially because you
get to watch your Offspring grow you get
to inspire them set an example you know
I always say that the best way to define
love is that you have someone in your
life whose happiness is more important
than your own I think men need that I
think that's that's one of the biggest
driving factors is that I don't have
time to worry about myself you know I
got to get out of myself because I got
to put food on the table I got to set an
example and if I do go through through
some [__] nobody's coming it's me it's a
it's it's a beautiful thing you know
love the beautiful thing about love is
the Way You Love a friend will be
different than the way you you love your
wife is going to be different than the
way you love your sibling is going to be
different than the way you love your kid
it's going to be different than the way
you love your parents but to experience
all these you know dimensions of Love is
a is a very unique thing uh how you keep
this going cuz you and I were talking
before this you said you know it was
just laughing about you got to keep to
stay relevant you got to keep this going
bro there's no there's no there's no
days off like what have you posted
lately what are you thinking about how
are you how are you coming up with
original [__] how you know who's the
next guest what's the next topic you
know how do you what do you you know I
think a lot of this is in inent I think
a lot of this comes from your upbringing
it's how you rev you know you just rev
hard all the time but you've got to have
days when you just don't want to do this
[__] anymore tell me what is what for
people who have trouble when they wake
up in the morning and they got all these
all these voices in their head what do
you what's your ritual what do you say
to yourself brother everything comes
down to Vision everything ISS Vision
okay you see it what what so so most
people their vision has accomplished at
32 years old they're married they have
kids they have a house they have a job
paying them 80 a year and that's it that
was the vision okay to some people it's
slightly bigger than that right and
maybe they go till 40 but almost
everybody the vision they had that they
were willing to work for becomes a
reality and then they stay there very
few people uh have a vision that they
won't disclose all of it they'll
disclose some of it maybe you'll know
80% of it maybe you'll know 90% of it
you're not going to know 100% of it
because there's something that's driving
them on why they're not stopping right
okay so for me um I don't like what's
going on in America I feel broke the
other day I make an offer to Tucker
Carlon when he was free this is three
months ago four months ago whatever I'm
$100 million and he chooses a retweet
from Elon Musk over my $100 million you
know what he publicly said he says hey
nice hundred million offer guys pbd you
know value T whatever you guys are
Elon musk's retweet is more valuable
than $100 million why let me explain why
if he posts a show on Twitter x
x and Elan doesn't retweet it let's say
he gets a million views let's say gets 2
million views let's say gets 5 million
views let's say gets 10 million views
but if he posts every video on Twitter
that he does once a week and Elon has
agreed to retweet every one of them what
is that worth to him what's the actually
price it out what is worth every one of
your episodes that you do on a weekly
basis that Elon will retweet one of them
that's 52 retweets a year to the number
one account on Twitter with 160 million
followers what does that mean to you he
posts a clip 49 million views 88 million
views 338 million views 63 million views
58 million views can't comp with that
but put a price to it let's put a price
tag what is 52 retweets from Elon musor
per year I mean you put a number I it's
it's well over 100 of course it is of
course it is so let me take 100 million
or let me get a retweet from Milan 52
times a year so you know what so that
moment I realized how broke I was that
moment I realized I I I I realized we
have to compete we're not there yet we
have to get clear we have to make money
so our consulting firm right now is
growing exponentially the consulting
firm will be a multi-billion dollar
Consulting consulting firm teaches
people how to sell no our consulting
firm hey you want to raise $50 million
you want us to put a pitch deck together
come through we'll help you put a pitch
deck together you're having a hard time
finding a CFO you don't know what
questions to ask to hire the right CFO
your last two didn't work out you want
us to help you find a CFO we help that
you got an issue going on with your
board right now five people can't agree
on anything you guys got a decision you
got to make on this hey can we come talk
you and your business partner have a
50/50% deal he's been fool and r on the
side doesn't come to the office any he
says you know F you I'm not giving you
the other part I don't need to work we
never negotiated that you need a
mediator you're trying to change your
comp plan in your there's so many
different things that we'll consult for
with these clients but the consulting
firm is going to grow we got three
products that right now we're marketing
we're going to get to the next one and
the next one and then you'll hear about
what happens with that by David
consulting.com but that's that part the
talent acquisition that we're doing and
we're breeding Talent internally we have
our own way of doing it that we're
excited about uh product development we
just recently launched an app Manet a
few months ago and man is now in 42
countries uh we we've invested a lot of
resources into it uh and in the last uh
uh 6 months we've had 100,000 downloads
of man and on top of that 10,000 nearly
10,000 transactions on man and here's
what man is uh six seven years ago I'm
talking to one of my lawyers this lawyer
I'm talking to for 7 minutes bills me
for 30 minutes I get pissed I call him
up I said bro this was a 7-minute call
what's this 30- minute bill for he says
minutes roll up I said not to 30 minutes
maybe to 10 minutes maybe if not 30 he
said I can't do anything I said what do
you charge by the minute he says no
lawyer charges by the minute
I said what if there's a platform that I
can pay you by the minute do you have a
minute to connect let's man for example
how many DMS do you get you can't get
back to what if what if anybody who's
dealt with lawyers anybody knows you
will get an $80,000 Bill and you'll be
like what the [__] is this about and you
don't know you're not you don't have a
timer you're not going to they're doing
that so they you just having a friendly
chat and they're paying somebody 40
bucks an hour to do they're charging 600
what the [__] is this you know and then
yeah try La yeah 1100 so so man that man
the app we have a product development
division you can you can so I can get a
lawyer off of the app no you can talk to
you can be on man guys want to DM you
you don't respond back you're hard to
get a hold of you're busy on man they'll
DM you but you could say I'll respond
back but it's 100 bucks a response so
it's 100 bucks you respond back in text
if they want to text you and they want
to respond in a video you can charge
whatever 200 bucks and you respond back
in a video if they want to have a 15 a
FaceTime with you could say I'll do 50
minutes for 1,000 bucks okay and people
will do that with you and the time goes
B the bottom I want to buy another 15
and you'll be amazed what things people
want to talk to you about so we got
influencers making 10 20 $50,000 a month
on M so that M side is so many people
right now are running a nonprofit
consulting firm man allows everybody a
YouTuber a Jiu-Jitsu guy a UFC guy a
lawyer a private Equity guy a therapist
to start a business with Consulting
Consulting right now is a trillion
dollar your industry $1 trillion a year
is being spent on Consulting right now
this is why the Mackenzie and these
companies are so powerful but yeah we we
want to our holding company we want to
be formidable we want to compete we want
to buy franchises we want to build one
of the most formidable media companies
in the world the next 10 20 years so
that's what we're excited about I'm so
excited and I'm just going to say I'm
I'm not going to take too much of your
time we got to get out of here because I
know you got backto backs but uh it just
feels like you're going to eventually
run for office I said it out loud I had
to I had to I had to make the
announcement here I just feel like in
Patrick bed David's head there is a
political speech coming and he's going
to take it to the
country you see how quiet he is that's
all I'm going to say so choose your
enemies
wisely you're funny choose your enemies
wisely you know I'm not born here I'm
not born here I know you can't be
president no and I'm not interested in
Governor at all you're not zero all
right zero you well you can be a king
maker that's exactly what I'm going to
be you're going to be a very good one
though very good one I'm excited about
that brother you're such a good guy you
you you haven't changed even a little
bit since when I met you and I've never
heard anybody say a bad word about you
especially the people that work for you
app they love you to death and you're a
good man and uh the book is choose your
enemies wisely and you hit me today with
something that at 56 years old give him
a second because I look a lot
younger well because my face is so tight
but uh that I I have not heard which is
you need somebody in your life who
breaks your heart and I mean that's a
forever thing so that's that's
incredible so uh I thank you bro you're
making the world a better place thank
you yeah man appreciate you this is
great dude my man thank
you